so we have a very real trailer to x-men
Days of Future past there are more than
a few reasons to be excited about the
summer movie season 2014 the rest is
your Days of Future past it's gonna be
one of them and in Days of Future past
the mutants are in war times Xavier is
working with magneto Wolverines a bit
older he has grain his hair which at
first I was like what year is this is
this like the near future 2015 I think
that Wolverines older means probably not
it's a given that the movie x-men Days
of Future past is not gonna follow the
comic book series Days of Future past
verbatim and in that there are gonna be
surprises there are uncertainties and
there's gonna be a lot of speculation
for this movie
all of which completely warranted and
justified side by side to ban this will
before demo beginners but it looks like
[ __ ] times so old Xavier is like hey
Wolverine you gotta help me out in the
past like he's saviors like all right
the only guy who can set [ __ ] right is
the guy who told me to go [ __ ] myself
back in the sixties ass cameo ever wake
up a million buddy and then what find me
convince me
this it's great to take the curbs I
should have started this video off
telling you this in the first place the
two most epic trailer songs ever made in
trailers are one the song from sunshine
which is in this trailer I encourage you
guys to know that that song is so good
and so cool that it transcends being
known as the song in the x-men origins
Wolverine trailer which I was surprised
they use the song from the x-men origins
Wolverine trailer since they're both
movies that take place in the x-men
universe and x-men origins Wolverine is
arguably the most hated one doesn't
matter though because it's a song from
sunshine and that song brings tears to
folks and it looks like young Xavier
James MacAvoy is in a big slump a
depression and Patrick Stewart's like
bear with me I was in I was a different
man back then just be patient
[Music]
which surprises me because from what I
saw of James McAvoy's Xavier in x-men
first class I would imagine that he
would just turn into older Xavier and it
just flows it wasn't a different man
back then II was actually pretty awesome
assertive why is smart Xavier in the 70s
though I don't know what they put in his
corn Flex but he probably listened to a
bit too much free bird and well we know
what comes with that magneto and Xavier
they have work together if they have a
common enemy but in this one it's almost
like Magneto's like I get it when I was
younger I was [ __ ] out where do I
find you
Huff's darker path which makes me think
why is young Xavier in a rut because he
was paralyzed and lost his friend Erik
and now Erik's out there doing stuff but
I don't think so I have a hundred and
fifty thousand theories going I imagine
who's gonna deal with alternate
realities and possibilities that may
have happened but haven't happened yet
the timeline of the other x-men movies
that we've had so far other than x-men
first class could be a different kind of
reality because Xavier does not look
happy and it's like they're like dude
you need to shape up otherwise that
shitty future that we're all fighting is
gonna happen please we need you to weak
saviours talking to each other oh and
then kick on the second most epic
trailer song ever used which is actually
the music that's in the trailer for
Pearl Harbor it's actually from The Thin
Red Line too if you're wondering
which makes me wonder at the beginning
of the trailer when you're Xavier go you
need to do for me what I once did for
you is he talking to Wolverine or is he
talking to magneto is he like Magneto
remember when I was like hey chap cheer
up and see the good in things is that
what they have to do for him now
[Music]
Wow Xavier you are angry theories are
already going around blogs and comments
sections that people are going to be
talking about this trailer Bryan Singer
kills it directing the first two x-men
movies x-men first class is actually my
favorite of the x-men movies it's like a
hybrid of those two awesome worlds have
come together to give us Days of Future
past my gripes about the trailer is one
gripe about the movie and the other end
the trailer what about the movies
Bishop's in it and he doesn't look that
cool he just doesn't he looks like he
walked off the set of an x-men TV show
there's something about it maybe he's
too young maybe it's a suit but I just
look at the guy and I'm like he who
knows though I remember when I first saw
a picture of Ian McKellen as magneto for
x-men 1 and wizard magazine before it
came out and I was like that looks
terrible and in the movie he actually
kicked ass and I liked his costume so it
works hey maybe when I see it in the
actual movie I like it but for now I
just don't like how Bishop looks in this
movie the other one is the segue between
the two trailer songs there really isn't
one patience isn't my strongest suit it
sounds like it's spliced into the middle
of the next part in the trailer you see
that see that again patience isn't my
strongest suit usually when someone's
screaming in a trailer you'll see them
like arc this scream up that could also
get the trailer music time to fade in
this one's just like yeah I suppose it's
supposed to be shocking and abrupt I'm
just saying it looks like an editing
mistake that the trailer Kicks complete
ass if you guys recognize things in this
trailer that actually happened in the
days of future past comic book don't
tell me about it
even though it's happened in a comic
book it is a spoiler if people don't
know about it for the movie you know
what I mean dude seriously
the people who messaged me and they're
like oh hey for a Winter Soldier this
sounds like oh thanks man this it's
that's why I don't talk about Game of
Thrones
all right so x-men Days of Future past
have you seen this trailer what did you
think about it don't lie you think it's
awesome whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]